what's going on guys this is Rob and
welcome back to the river Roundup our
weekly series where we cover all the
news and rumors that you may have missed
over the course of the week and let's
get into it let's talk about this so as
our first piece of news by the way we're
gonna have a lot of Black Adam stuff
here because the movie's coming out and
all kinds of little tidbits are being
revealed for this film but in our first
of news rumors abound specifically
coming from Casey Walsh who's just a
Movie Insider that dumps information
much like Daniel Rickman or Daniel rpk
as some people know him this guy's come
out and said the supposedly Henry Cavill
is going to appear in the Black Adam
film as Superman now do not take this as
an absolute so do not get on Twitter and
say oh my God everybody Henry Cavill is
going to be Superman and Black Adam Rob
at geek culture explain told me so
that's not what I'm saying it's just a
rumor that's circulating around out
there now the evidence being used for
this is a scenario or a situation in the
film where Black Adam basically says
there's no one on earth who can stop me
and the response is good thing I'm not
from this earth now the reality here is
that when it comes to Dwayne Johnson's
Black Adam in the Warner Brothers
Cinematic Universe there's only two
people we really want to see him fight
the first one is Shazam because Black
Adam is historically a Shazam villain
but I will say that that's mostly comic
book fans who want to see that what
casual moviegoers want to see is Black
Adam versus Superman that's really what
they want to see because Superman's the
big heavy hitter in the Warner Brothers
Cinematic Universe or the DC Cinematic
Universe and Black Adam really like
Dwayne Johnson as pitching him as like
the replacement for Superman so what
better way to see these two guys kind of
meet each other than to watch them beat
the hell out of each other it's like
Batman and Superman and DC Comics right
every time DC reboots and the two of
them meet for the first time Batman and
Superman fight it's been a thing since
the Dark Knight Returns so again whether
or not this is true has yet to be seen
but it would be awesome if it happened
but in another piece of news because the
blows just keep coming from Warner
Brothers apparently there was a new
trailer that was released for Black Adam
that featured footage from the Joss
Whedon Justice League film instead of
the Zack Snyder Justice League film as
you guys can imagine this pissed off all
the Zack Snyder fans now I know I know
you're probably asking yourself but Zack
Snyder fans don't matter why would that
why would that be relevant at all and
you're right Zack Snyder fans don't
matter but the thing about this is
they're really the only fans Warner
Brothers has left so they might as well
not piss him off and so in order to
appease the Zack Snyder fans what ended
up happening is Warner Brothers took the
trailer down they removed the Joss
Whedon Justice League scene and replaced
it with the Zack Snyder Justice League
scene and re-uploaded it which appears P
like 5 000 people among the millions who
may go see this movie so it's one of
those things where DC just kind of shows
that they've got their priorities in the
wrong place in terms of who they're
trying to appease because I don't think
most people even realize what had gone
on in that trailer But continuing on
with our Black Adam discussion here
apparently there's been rumors
circulating around out there that Black
Adam in the Justice League is supposed
to happen now Grace Randolph came out
and said that apparently what's actually
going on is Dwayne Johnson is pitching
the idea to Warner Brothers of Black
Adam versus the Justice League versus
The Suicide Squad potentially even
featuring characters like Amanda Waller
which would just be amazing to see now
whether or not this is true of course
again it's really just a rumor but the
funny thing about this is the Shazam 2
director David Sandberg came out and was
like I don't really know if that's true
or not but I will say it'd be hilarious
to see Black Adam fight pretty much
everybody in the DC Universe except for
Shazam which would be funny I'm not
gonna lie it would be pretty hilarious
in terms of when these two guys are
gonna fight and when they're gonna meet
I don't really know right like Zachary
Levi was exceedingly Coy about that it's
San Diego Comic-Con if you guys remember
he was asked that question like when are
you gonna fight Black Adam and he's like
well I mean you know
that's one of those things and like and
we never really got a definitive answer
and even when The Rock was asked who
would win in a fight between you and
Superman The Rock was like well I mean
you know I'm Dwayne Johnson probably me
and like that was basically it right so
there's not really been any information
coming out as to whether any of these
rumors are true in any real capacity but
I will say this I think that Black Adam
has really built up a lot of hype among
people and while they're not overly
vocal about it while you don't see posts
on Twitter and read it all over the
place talking about Black Adam and it
certainly doesn't feel like the kind of
hype that you got when it came to like
Infinity war and end game and a lot of
the other MCU projects I think this is
actually a very exciting project and I
think it's the most exciting people have
been for the DC Cinematic Universe for
quite some time so assuming this movie
is done right and assuming it's done
well this could actually be the shot in
the arm that the Warner Brothers
Cinematic Universe needs in order to
revitalize interest in the DC Cinematic
Universe as a whole so it could
literally be this thing that saves it
it's entire really possible but of
course we'll find out on October 21st
October 21st when Black Adam comes out
but moving away from Black Adam and
focusing on She-Hulk for a second the
She-Hulk TV show has failed to make the
Nielsen top charts now for those of you
guys who don't know the significance of
that Nielsen is a ratings company so
whenever you see these news articles and
stuff where they're like this show got
this many millions of viewers over the
course of its whole first season those
are Nielsen ratings they track Episode
by episode and it's what a lot of
companies use to determine whether or
not they're going to continue a show at
all it's what Netflix uses Disney uses
the whole nine yards everybody uses it
the result of this is that the the
Revelation that She-Hulk has not topped
the charts when it came to Nielsen it's
surprising given the nature of the fact
that it's a Marvel product and in fact
this is the first time that's happened
this is also drawing a lot of people to
the conclusion that Marvel products
aren't really doing anything for Disney
plus that the reality is people aren't
really signing up for Disney Plus in in
droves to watch this now in truth I
think it's less to do with Marvel as a
whole and I think it has more to do with
the products that they're creating
granted She-Hulk certainly does have an
audience and that audience loves
She-Hulk for me as a person I think
Marvel screwed the pooch by not turning
the show into something where she hoped
was basically representing some y or
z-list villain every episode and that
was just a part of the episode but it
shows her being a lawyer and doing that
stuff and it shows us just how wonky and
Goofy some of the villains or even
heroes really are out there in the
Marvel landscape but as a result of that
the show that we got basically feels
like pretty white kids with problems and
it doesn't really resonate with me
because I'm not a pretty white girl and
I don't have to deal with pretty white
girl problems and so it's just not
really my thing and that kind of seems
to be the sentiment among a lot of
people out there and so this is really
the question that I would pitch to you
guys when it comes to the success or
lack of success of She-Hulk depending on
which side of this aisle that you're on
is the Daredevil hype hurting She-Hulk
is it one of those things where people
are just like I'm not going to watch it
until Daredevil shows up are we
literally going to see this situation
where the She-Hulk show came out and the
rating started going down like that and
then you get a spike with Daredevil and
then it drops off when Daredevil's not
in it anymore is that one of those
things that's creating problems for the
show do people just not care about her
character and they want to see
characters they do care about like
Daredevil But continuing on with our
coverage of Marvel Cinematic Universe
stuff and just talking about some cool
things according to Leanne Yang who's a
stunt performer for Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of Madness we actually
ended up getting some measure of a
preview of what would have been a scene
in Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness
that had it not been cut would have made
the movie rated R specifically the scene
has to do with the Scarlet Witch no it's
not a dirty scene
get your minds out of the gutter so
here's the thing
would have been a hyper violent scene
and it would have taken place during the
battle at kamartaj and it would have
been an exceedingly brutal battle now in
hindsight looking back at Doctor Strange
Multiverse Madness I think that's one of
those moments of the movie that probably
should have been more brutal it was cool
to see but I think it should have been
more extreme because it would have shown
just how far the Scarlet Witch had
fallen and just how powerful she was in
the face of all these Sorcerers she was
going against such as it is the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is largely a
family-friendly property so they kind of
have to keep it family friendly in terms
of the content that they're producing
because that's where you make the most
money but continuing on here we have a
leaked photo of Scott Lang as Ant-Man
literally looking like he just got the
hell beat out of him and we don't really
even know where this thing comes from
but a lot of people are saying this is
basically a moment after he fought King
the Conqueror now we don't know exactly
how King is going to be handled in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe but something
to understand when it comes to Kane the
conquer in his base form meaning you
strip away all the technology and
everything there's really nothing
special about it right I mean he's given
himself enhancements over time that have
allowed him to face off against people
that he normally wouldn't face off
against but as a normal guy he's
literally that just a normal guy it's
all the enhancements and the technology
that he had done to himself that made
him more capable having said that if
they handle him in any way that's even
comparable to his comic book counterpart
in terms of strength speed durability
all that kind of stuff yeah this is
probably him having beaten the hell out
of Scott Lang either that or it was the
forces of Kang having beat up Scott Lang
again it's a single image taken out of
context and we have no idea what this
ties into for all we know he just fell
down a really long set of steps we have
no clue what it is that happened to him
now continuing on uh the trailer for
Loki from d23 has leaked online and I'm
sure a lot of you guys have seen it by
now admittedly we've held off to a
degree because we weren't entirely sure
how that would be handled that literally
Disney and them were pulling the trailer
down so our fear here at geek culture
explained was that if we did a trailer
breakdown on the leaked trailer that'd
be a copyright strike and we get three
of those and YouTube shuts our whole
Channel down and YouTube doesn't really
ask questions when everybody whenever
anybody applies a strike right they
apply a strike then you can appeal and
depending on how much money that person
pays YouTube and AD Revenue YouTube may
or may not help you so it really kind of
depends Disney's got some Deep Pockets
pretty sure they're able to make that
kind of stuff happen but we ultimately
held off because we weren't really sure
how this was going to be handled across
the YouTube platform but in one of the
bigger things transitioning to gaming
and one of the bigger pieces of news to
happen I don't know how many of you guys
caught it some kid out in Britain hacked
Rockstar Games and just dumped footage
of GTA 6's developments right like dump
footage of the game just showing
everybody what it looks like now that
kid has since been arrested but I gotta
say man it takes balls to hack a triple
a gaming studio like that and dump GTA 6
footage out there for the world to see
if anything is well this does lead to
this kid's arrest Rockstar Games had to
be keeping for joy as soon as this
happened because people don't hack
gaming Studios and release footage about
games that no one cares about so what
this shows and just as highly as this
was just spread around the internet it
shows there's a ton of interest in Grand
Theft Auto 6 because it's just taken so
long for us to get it for those of you
guys who aren't really aware of the
reason why is because once GTA 5 was
released with an online component
Rockstar game realized they could make a
lot of money doing that so instead of
developing GTA 6 they focus all their
efforts on milking the fan base for
money with the online component of GTA
5. so ultimately GTA 6's production was
delayed but now we're finally getting
the game so you can rest assured given
the online popularity of GTA 5 that
Rockstar Games is probably going to
continue this pattern of delaying the
development and releases of future GTA
installments because they can make a
bunch of money on the online component
of the Grand Theft Auto games the only
way to get around that is to stop paying
them with the Grand Theft Auto online
component but going into our final topic
and this is probably one of the more
controversial topics that we have
apparently twitch has come out and made
two major changes to the platform so on
October 18th twitch will officially ban
any unlicensed form of gambling and a
lot of this is because a streamer came
out and admitted to scamming their fans
in order to feed their gambling
addiction which was pretty huge now this
basically led to Twitch saying there's
no more unlicensed gambling right like
unless you're going with a licensed
gambling site you cannot stream it so
luckily what will happen is what twitch
usually does when it comes to bands
whether or not you get banned will
depend on how popular your channel is
but the second thing that twitch has
done and this is what really pissed off
the twitch Community is they've changed
the revenue split so if those guys who
aren't familiar with that you can gain
revenue from a variety of different
sources when it comes to twitch but one
of the things they do is they have a 70
30 Revenue split basically meaning you
get 70 of the revenue they get 30
they've asked that and now it's 50 50.
and twitch basically came along and said
the reason why they were doing that was
just because of rising costs and having
to tighten the belt and different things
along those lines now this has led to a
lot of twitch streamers saying they're
going to abandon the platform and
they're going to come over to YouTube
instead uh for those of you guys who are
over on Twitch and considering coming to
YouTube I've been on YouTube for almost
a decade it ain't much better over here
so I'd I'd be a little I'd be a little
wary right I'd just be aware this is not
one of those situations where the grass
is legitimately greener on the other
side
just look at any number of the
complaints when it comes to the YouTube
fan base the reality is it's just kind
of happening across the board that a lot
of people are looking at twitch and
they're saying this is another instance
of twitch basically leaving their
creators out to dry the twitch is
inconsistent in terms of how they
enforce their policies I mean the
reality here is that whenever you have
people especially a community-based
group like twitch where those
individuals who run the company end up
making friends with people in the twitch
Community you're gonna have bias you're
gonna have unfair disciplinary practices
because nobody wants to be the one to
ban their friends or one member of the
twitch staff bans a person and then that
person who is banned has a friend who's
also on the twitch staff and their
friend lifts the ban and then nothing
ever really gets done it's really one of
those things where it's just kind of the
Wild West in terms of how twitch manages
their platform which is I think one of
the reasons why twitch is really doing
what they're doing because in truth the
reality is when we look around at the
idea of live streaming it's not really
that big of a thing anymore right it's
not nearly as big as it used to be and
in fact what I think you're seeing is
you're seeing this shift away from live
streaming and even long-form videos to a
degree on YouTube and it's just a huge
emphasis on short form content Tick Tock
YouTube shorts Instagram reels if
anybody even uses that just that kind of
a thing right you're seeing people
shifting over to short form content even
on Tick Tock people are actually
streaming there instead of streaming on
Twitch because it's easier to grow there
because of the nature of the algorithm
of course again you don't really have a
monetization strategy on Tick Tock so
it's hard to make money but the fact
remains people want to be ahead of the
curve they want to be there and they
want to have a sizable audience so that
that when those monetization strategies
come around and you can make money it's
just that easy right they just fire up a
video and they're suddenly making x
amount of dollars as opposed to having
to build up to that income but at the
end of the day I say all this to say
much like anything else cash is King and
so twitch is tightening the belt because
they're basically dumping a ton of money
on hosting the platform largely they're
funded by Amazon but I imagine Amazon's
just kind of like you need to get your
financial house in order before we dump
any more money into you right we're not
going to put money into what's basically
a money pit so twitch is making changes
across the platform here's the question
you have to ask is the strategy that
twitch is using to basically fix its
financial situation is it going to run
people off the platform or is this one
of those instances when twitch streamers
just really complain but they just don't
go anywhere right like YouTubers We
complain about YouTube all the time but
we don't leave so what reason does
YouTube have to actually change any of
their policies so let me know what you
guys think down in the comments section
thank you all for watching and I will
catch you all later
peace